The virus is really hitting
all of China at once.
The forecast for deaths
in China reach as high as
China's road to reopening
is a little bit like
that Ernest Hemingway phrase:
Gradually, and then suddenly.
The pressure has really
been building for a year now
since the arrival of Omicron
because that variant is
just so transmissible
that China's classic playbook
of lockdowns, mass testing
was becoming less and less
effective against stopping spread.
Then there were these
unprecedented protests
that happened at the end of November.
People taking to the streets,
some even calling for
president Xi to step down.
Since then, China has
basically let it rip.
All of these measures
now have been overturned.
The only thing that remains for China is
these travel curbs that we expect
to be eased quite soon as well.
What we're seeing right now
is that really initial stage
of infection that we saw
in so many other countries in early 2020
where suddenly over a couple of days,
almost everybody you know is infected.
What's really worrisome
coming after this stage
is when serious illness
and fatalities will set in.
There's a lot of concern
over how the elderly
especially are under vaccinated
and they're vaccinated
with Chinese vaccines,
which we know are not as
effective as the western mRNAs.
The health system is under strain.
Officials are telling people,
please don't come to the hospitals
unless you're seriously sick.
They're trying to prioritize
the most vulnerable.
The virus is really hitting
all of China at once.
I think we can see the same thing
really happen in all major cities
The virus is really hitting
all of China at once.
But as we've seen in so many
other countries around the world,
the waves keep coming back.
There may be another variant,
which is a really big unknown
that experts are quite concerned about.
Because you're talking about
1.4 billion people.
The more people get the virus,
the more it evolves.